Welcome.
My name is Malika Saada Saar.
I'm Google's senior counsel on civil and human rights.
You know,
about a year ago,
the great human rights lawyer,
Brian Stevenson,
came to Google,
came to our Tgi f where all of us come together in mountain view and t gif is
live stream to all of our employees.
And so as a company we came together to welcome Brian and Brian said to us,
challenged us to bear witness,
to be proximate to the human costs of mass incarceration.
And so over the year,
in the last 10 months,
in fact,
we have been doing criminal justice forms within Google to really do what Brian
asks us to do,
to bear witness and to be proximate to the human costs of mass incarceration.
We've had these conversations in different parts of our company,
we've thought about and continue to ask the question of how do we use our
platforms to disrupt mass incarceration?
Because we know that what we do at Google is disrupt,
disrupt for good,
and if anything needs to be disrupted,
it's the over criminalization of our black and brown communities.
But most of how we've had that conversation has really been without the words
and lived experiences of women and girls.
And so today,
as part of women's history month,
we want to be able to delve deeply into what is mass incarceration from the
perspective of women and girls.
When we talk about achieving racial justice,
how do we do it from a gendered Lens?
Up to 80% of women behind bars have been subject to some form of sexual
violence.
Sexual violence is the primary predictor of girls going behind bars and women
and girls are the fastest growing prison populations.
We must have this conversation as part of our overall commitment to disrupting
mass incarceration.
We cannot have any real comprehensive discourse around criminalization of black
and brown communities without centering the experiences of women and girls.
And with that,
it is my absolute honor and privilege to introduce to you the founder and
executive director of the National Council for formerly incarcerated and
incarcerated women and girls
Angio,
James
[inaudible].
Hi everybody.
Thank you.
I'm not going to be labor.
Um,
anything beyond what Malika has said,
I cannot underscore enough the importance of the words that she did say.
I want to say thank you to everybody here at Google,
both in this room and those of you who are on live stream for tuning in to this
incredibly important issue.
And I think without me going on any further,
you will understand why it was so important by the end of our time here
together.
Um,
Miss Alice,
are you there?
I'm here.
Can you see me at all?
I know I don't see you right now.
Okay,
well I love you.
I don't know what I'm doing is telling me to do something.
What foe here?
Hi Miss Alice.
There you go.
All right.
Oh,
I see now.
There you are.
Hi,
how are you darling?
Okay,
so we're going to begin our conversation.
You are seeing uh,
Ms. Alice Marie Johnson and I'm going to tell you very briefly so that we can
get to Ms. Johnson and you're going to hear from her for the rest of the time
that,
that we're having our discussion together about the work of the National
Council.
We are a platform that we have created a really starting out because we knew
that our voices needed to be heard.
I mantra is nothing about us without us because we are the experts,
the women and girls who have gone through the experiences who have been directly
affected by an incredibly unjust,
racist,
classist and discriminatory criminal justice system.
We are the experts that need to be at the forefront and at the table and
creating the policy for not just change,
not for reforming a criminal justice system that we don't believe can be
reformed,
but in creating and shifting radically to a human justice system and what that
entails.
So the National Council of foreign rate and formerly incarcerated women and
girls was created to connect all of the powerful,
brilliant,
courageous,
brave,
incarcerated and formerly incarcerated women and girls across this country who
are doing that work as the experts to create the change that we know needs to
happen.
You're going to hear from many of them here today and you are privileged to have
the voice of the experience of the women that you will hear from today.
Starting with Miss Alice and the Obama Administration started a project called
the clemency project 2014 obviously it was back in 2014 and we went to the mat
under the leadership of our clemency expert,
Amy Pulver,
who was a woman who served years in the federal prison system prior to her
sentence been commuted by president,
Bill Clinton and Amy.
We have this thing.
When we leave the prison doors and we're walking out the door,
everybody says,
don't look back.
Don't look back.
It's like a curse.
We love you.
We want to see you go do not look back.
If you look back,
it's like the curse going to bring you back until we kind of leave there and we
don't look back.
Amy Povo looked back.
She never stopped.
Looking back from the day that she left that prison,
when President Bill Clinton commuted her sentence,
she started,
the organization can do clemency and please check it out.
You were going to see some of the faces of the women including Miss Alice that
are part of that.
Well,
unfortunately,
or fortunately,
of the very small number of the thousands of women that should,
that met President Obama has criteria,
but somehow we're left behind.
50 of our women did make it out under the leadership of Amy Poba and,
and the women of the council and women across this country that went to the mat
to fight,
to push these women out of prison.
Ms. Alice Johnson fit those criteria,
unfortunately.
And even though she's been in a prison for decades,
was not one of the women that we were able to push up.
And this is incredibly painful for us.
And I'm gonna stop there and I'm going to ask Miss Alison [inaudible],
we love you.
We understand how incredible your sales is in a federal prison speaking to us
right now.
And I want you to begin Miss Alice by telling us about you and about your story
and why you're sitting in that federal prison.
Okay?
Okay.
My name is Alice Murray.
Johnathan and obey Sir.
Yes.
Of this year,
I'll be 62 years old.
I've already spent a third of my life
in 1996 my life drastically changed forever.
I was convicted as a first time don valid drug offender instead of the life in
federal prison.
I'd always thought that all is the most heinous crimes warranted a life without
parole sentence.
I have the exact same sentence as Charles Manson.
Prior to coming to prison,
I lived at,
I guess you could say a pretty protective life.
I never expected anything like this to happen to me.
I had worked in various professional positions.
Uh,
I was working at Federal Express.
I had did a manager with Fedex for 10 years.
I was also a facilitator who trained other people for management.
When I lost my job,
uh,
10 years with Fedex,
I can tell you that my life literally began to spiral out of control.
I made one of the worst choices that I've ever made in my life,
which I deeply regret.
I became involved in a drug conspiracy.
I had never sold two outs.
I had never used drugs and I can tell you I literally got in over my head,
but I tell you,
I made some very different choices when I came to prison.
I would have tell you real quickly,
when I was a young girl,
I had someone ask me,
Alice,
what do you want to be when you grow up?
And I said,
I want it to be an incredible woman.
I said,
what is an incredible woman?
It's a woman who goes down in history who make changes in life,
who makes her a print in life and impact people lives.
That's the kind of warmth that I wanted to be.
I decided when I came to prison that because I was in prison,
prison bars don't have to contain your dreams Asti or wanted to be an incredible
woman.
So I looped around the my view environment to see how I could impact this
society in prison for good.
So I started serving others and making a difference in their lives.
I picked up my pen and I started writing plays,
plays that we're the largest indict participation programs in the prison.
People who felt they could do anything,
they learned how to do theatrical productions.
They learn how to act.
I started choreographic dance.
I found people that the gift of artistry was stir it up to them and they made
beautiful,
beautiful backdrops and I played,
became that place became known everywhere.
I also started mentoring women to see if I could help them be tier from a life
of crime.
I use experience that I had with interviewing and job preparedness to prepare
other wedding to go outside and be productive citizens.
So I want to,
I want us to have the opportunity to sell is to talk a little bit about the
sacks at we don't have available to us right now,
the clemency project.
We do not have that.
We have a justice,
we have a justice department now that wants to turn the clocks back to a place
in time that is dark and draconian and something that with all of the education
that we have learned over the years and throughout the Obama administration
about the need to decarcerate.
Why Miss Alice,
you are in a prison,
one of many federal women's prisons that are full of women who were there and
only but for conspiracy laws in this country that allow these women to be thrown
in and charged and held responsible for this the same amount as the person who
is the leader of the drug ring.
Why Miss Alice?
Why is it so incredibly important that we continue and raise awareness in places
like this about the need to push and to continue to push for the freedom of
women like yourself through clemency?
Well,
I can say this about conspiracy.
Many of the women in here were women who did not have those types of roles,
but they are charged with leadership roles.
They have to take on the responsibility of entire conspiracy because I was dumb.
I was eating of a sack because I had never been in prison.
I didn't even know people who have served time,
so I didn't know what a conspiracy charge meant.
It means that you are charged with every element of the crime.
You are held responsible for every act that anyone else has committed.
Whether you had knowledge of what they were doing and that that's why it's
called conspiracy.
So it becomes a catchall for everything.
And these women,
most of them are mothers.
I say 95% of them are mothers.
And I tell you,
we know that women,
not to say anything about the mail,
but the mother is the nucleus of a family.
When a mother is taken out of the home,
so many times the family is split apart.
When a man is taken out of the home,
the woman will hold it down both when the women most of the time,
and it's just the truth,
the children I sent away to live with relatives,
foster care,
and too many times they're sent to the streets to be raised by the streets and
the cycle of incarceration continues.
So this calls of women and girls is saving the families.
Yeah,
I was glad that this,
you were a mother,
Miss Alice.
Yes.
You were a mother and you know directly what that is like to be a mother who is
incarcerated for all of the years that you have been in prison.
And I want to just again command you Miss Alice for your courage to still stay
with us as part of the team to raise awareness because it must have been
incredibly difficult to have an opportunity through the clemency project to
maybe gain your freedom.
You're doing something that you deserved a lot of skin in the game.
We weren't asking for any favors on your behalf.
You earned your freedom and yet to have been denied.
I know it was difficult for us.
We still are challenged with it every single day.
Miss Alice,
we are here as your team fighting to bring you home,
but why is it important that we use our voices to encourage this administration
and future administrations to use clemency to push women like yourself out who
deserve to come home?
The fact that there is no parole in the federal system for most of us,
for me clemency had been our only hope so to not push for clemency is to take
away their hope because we have exhausted all of the means.
I have not been sitting still.
I filed motions after motions and the court,
but clemency in itself is an act of mercy and forgiveness.
And will you see a person like myself who is did a complete turnaround in their
life who has gad?
I get so much support.
I stand,
lift fought so hard.
The clemency project was like putting the carrots and then draw it back because
we all have so much hope that that was going to come through because I knew I
fit the criteria.
But as you see,
I left behind and I'm still here and this is what I want to say to Google.
Google is a company that has been greatly blessed to whom much is given,
much is required when you use your voice.
People listen,
when you champion a cause,
I leadership listens.
You may say,
am I my brother's or sister's keeper?
And I say to you today that if not you,
then who?
If not now,
then when I don't want to die in prison to say later may be too late for me.
I'm already 62 I've already spent two decades in prison.
So I believe that as responsible citizens,
we do have a responsibility to each other.
We do.
It is not just a social issue that you put on the agenda that sounds good on
paper.
It's something that you have to take to heart when you see me and so many others
like me,
you see I'm just a representative but very small representative,
but there's many more just like me and I don't believe that the public is safe
because I'm here.
I'm not valid and I've already spent 20 years and I've had 100% clear conduct.
I'm so,
I was free trial bond,
but two years I was trusted enough to be at all but after my arrest I've proven
that I'm a reformed woman,
but there's still no help for me unless someone takes on this challenge of
helping us in mass incarceration and using what you have been gifted with a
blessed competent.
We need you.
I appreciate it if you would help us.
Thank you Miss Alice,
Miss Alice,
as we always do,
we want to remind you that we are here.
Your team is out here.
We will never,
we are here.
Yeah.
Thank you.
And you know that we are going to continue and we are going to continue to this
work hopefully by raising the consciousness level of what you have described
perfectly.
An incredible organization,
uh,
here at Google and the power and the brilliance that they have that we hope that
they recognize.
Not that they're special people,
but they are privileged and people who are privileged to have a responsibility
to the rest of the human race.
So I thank you again for again,
coming with us on the road and sharing what is so very difficult and to let
everybody understand when I hang up this phone call with Miss Alice,
I'm going to go and I'm going to sit down and I'm going to listen to the rest of
the women and girls who are here with us today.
Miss Alice is going to go back to a prison into a prison cell that she has been
in for more than 20 years.
We need to bring her home and we hope that all of you here at Google will help
us to do that.
Thank you Miss Alice.
We love you.
I love you too.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
I'm going to call your Topeka or up here cause I don't know what I'm supposed to
do now Miss Alice.
But we know that you like to hang out and,
and speak of.
What am I going to do in here?
Okay.
We're going to,
I'm not going to let you hang out there and,
and cause Miss Alison's going to cut off when she cuts off because she is
calling from a federal prison and they only get a tiny window of opportunity.
But we like to let her hang out and listen for as long as she can because it's
like giving her a break from being in the prison.
So I love you Miss Alice.
We're going to move on.
Okay,
I'll talk to you later.
I love you Mo Topeka.
Miss Alice was speaking to you
right there to pick him.
Ileka you know what?
Okay.
Thank you.
I'm going to ask.
Thank you us.
So we want to focus on the experience of women behind bars.
And Miss Alice did a powerful,
powerful job in helping us to begin to understand that more deeply.
And we are so honored and privileged to have your voice,
Miss Alice and we're going to make sure that your voice is heard through all the
corridors of Google.
I want each of you to introduce yourselves and then let's start our
conversation.
Okay.
Thank you Malika and Google for having us be a part of this conversation and
conversation as definitely necessary and crucial at this time.
Uh,
my name is Mia.
She Benton.
I'm with the woman and Justice Project and I'm pretty much,
we sent it a leaderships directly impacted,
um,
women to shift the dynamic change to allow the criminal justice system to be
dismantled.
Okay.
Good afternoon.
My name is Topeka Sam.
I am the national organizer for the National Council for incarcerated and
formerly incarcerated women and girls.
I'm a formerly incarcerated woman and I'm also the founder of the ladies of hope
ministries.
And our goal,
a method national council is to end the incarceration of women and girls.
Yeah.
So I wanted to ask each of you to talk in more depth around how mass
incarceration has impacted you directly.
Okay.
Um,
so mass incarceration,
like I was arrested at the age of 19,
I was two months pregnant and I did a total of four years in three different
states,
New York,
New Jersey and Pennsylvania.
And while incarcerated,
I gave birth to my daughter at the Bedford Hills correctional facility,
which is the maximum facility in New York state.
And I spent many birthdays behind bars.
And you know,
when you think about your 21st birthday,
you really don't think about celebrating inside behind the cell with the woman
you barely know.
But you know,
you make the best of it.
And as women we make the best of I situations.
Um,
I was also fortunate to be able to go into the nursery.
Bedford hills correctional facility has a nursery,
would they allow the woman to stay with the children up to a year.
And I was able to bond with my daughter and after I sent her home,
they transfer me to beyond correctional facility,
which is the medium security facility in New York state on a borderline of
Canada.
And from there,
I didn't receive another visit from neither one of my children because I had a
son that was one years old when I went inside.
And this is not like a unique situation,
75% a woman that are incarcerated at the time,
our moms.
And I would one of those moms that was far away and did not have access to being
able to see my children and speaking on a phone or letters.
Don't cut it when you have young children and then don't cut it for any children
because you don't,
you're not afforded the bond that you need to nurture and to bring them up.
Um,
so after my four years,
I came home and reunited with my,
my son and my daughter.
[inaudible]
so,
um,
my,
impact with incarceration has started.
I just,
just being in an African American woman,
um,
you know,
family members and things that have been incarcerated or friends,
but,
um,
my family,
my parents,
they were entrepreneurs,
franchise owners,
and they had,
um,
had us living in an area where we were the only black family and partly was to
protect us from what was happening within the country and the things that they
went through being from New York City.
And when I went off to go to college,
um,
is when I got exposed directly to different things that were really happening in
the worlds and started making poor choices and really buy into the narrative of
what being black but like in America.
Um,
and that entailed dating guys who may have been,
um,
drug dealing and things of that nature.
And then,
and then not even understanding what had happened in this country to even caused
that to happen within our communities.
So,
um,
I would,
I had gotten in trouble and I would get arrested and then go on probation.
And it was the cycle yet still in college and school,
still maintaining,
um,
employment and building a career or starting a business.
And so when I was incarcerated in federal prison,
I was incarcerated for three and a half years.
And part of what Miss Alice spoke about and when we,
oh,
she just touched on,
was the fact that I had met so many women who had children and so many women,
um,
in the federal prison we are taking,
you know,
far,
far away.
And in the northeast,
Danbury,
Connecticut was the only women's federal prison.
And I was camp designated.
So I was in Danbury.
And you had women from all up and down the east coast and Midwest who were there
yet.
They,
I would be in the visiting room and there would be no one there.
And partly is because you had the parents who were home,
who are elderly on fixed incomes,
who were taking care of the children.
I couldn't had to choose whether or not they could to have the children go to
see their parents or feed the children and make sure that they were okay.
And then a meeting women who had,
had already done 20 years in prison.
Um,
I knew at that point that it was my responsibility to then take what it was that
I learned even being impacted by conspiracy charge.
And by the grace of God,
I did not get life in prison,
but those conspiracy laws are just that I'd had no drugs in my case at all yet I
was charged with having 80 kilos of cocaine.
So when you look at just how that law is and what it's in place and what it does
to our communities,
specifically women and girls,
um,
one of the policies and the reform that we're doing at the national council is
to change that conspiracy law.
Um,
so now as a national organizer,
we go around the country.
We are mobilizing,
hoping to get 100,000 members,
which includes formerly incarcerated,
incarcerated women,
directly impacted children of incarcerated parents and people like you who are
movement family and allies who can help us in moving this work and getting the
message out so that we can end the incarceration of women and girls.
So Topeka,
I want to just surface more what you're talking about with the conspiracy
charges because we know right that most women who are behind bars at federal and
state correctional facilities,
our mothers to children under the age of 18 we know that most women and mothers
behind bars are first time nonviolent felons.
What is going on with the conspiracy charges that first time nonviolent felons
who are mothers to children under the age of 18 are being put behind bars for 20
years or a lifetime sentence.
Can you explain that more to us?
Absolutely.
It's happening because,
um,
it's a,
it's a like a retaliation tactic.
It's used because if you don't cooperate in whatever the charges are,
and a lot of times the women really have no idea what's going on.
I mean,
think about you.
Do you really know what your boyfriend or your husband is doing when they leave
you?
You don't.
And so you know,
they want you to then speak on information that you don't make up.
Information is people that you may not have even met in the conspiracy yet.
If you don't cooperate,
you end up getting hit with as Miss Alice described,
everything that's in that charge.
And then you ending up in life in prison because of the sentencing guidelines
and the guidelines chart and the fact that you are charged based on the amount
of drugs that is said to have not actually have.
So they,
it's a,
they call a ghost dope.
You don't even have to find it yet.
You'll be charged with it.
And that's how the system is being manipulated in so many women and girls of
being caught and swept into the conspiracy.
And yet it's really conspiracy against our women.
And girls,
do you want to add to that mule shoe?
Um,
no.
So I'm going to ask you a different question to add to,
but I just want to make sure that people understand what you've said because
this is really one of the key ways that when we talk about the war on drugs and
the over prosecution of black and brown communities and the over criminalization
that has happened,
these can pee.
Conspiracy charges are at the heart of how we talk about the war on drugs,
devastating impact on our communities,
but often what doesn't get talked about is the particular ways that it's played
out in the lives of women.
So Miyoshi I wanted to talk to you about this issue of conditions of confinement
for our women and mothers.
Um,
when,
when I was heading up an NGO on gender based violence,
some women who were previously incarcerated talk to me about how they had been
during Labor and childbirth shackled and,
and I thought they were explaining to me like some crazy thing that was an ab
are in violation of practice and policy at a southern prison because they were
coming from Tennessee.
Um,
and I started to find out that actually shackling women during labor and
childbirth is standard procedure.
It was standard procedure in all of our federal correctional facilities.
Fortunately,
we were able to change that.
It remains standard procedure in most of our state prisons.
So let me be clear in what I'm saying.
When a woman behind bars who is pregnant is in labor and childbirth.
She is shackled,
shackled by her arms,
her legs.
I heard one case of a belly shackled during labor.
Can you talk to us more about this policy and the incredible work that you've
done to change it?
So
I was one of those women.
I was illegally shackled and New York state.
Um,
they have,
uh,
we had a low of 2009 with law that banned the barberry Shakhlin and pregnant
women when I went in and 2009,
I was pregnant.
I gave birth to my daughter in 2010.
And
when you're inside,
you don't know your rights and as one of the ways they control you by not
allowing you to educate yourself or to educate you on what your rights are.
So the less you know the best for them.
So I didn't know that it was illegal to shackle me while I was in labor are
delivering.
And my experience was,
I was.
So just imagine for me like for anyone giving birth,
like you're joyous moment,
a moment that she's supposed to be with your loved one,
shift family,
Sharon and welcome and anew life and that moment being distorted and corrupted
by a correctional officer who doesn't have any good intentions towards you.
It's malicious energy.
And for me,
while I was giving birth,
I had the correction officers standing in between my legs while pushing while
the doctor was pushing.
And
you know,
you want to say something and you want to like trying to understand like how can
someone in a right mind think it's okay.
Like how is this humanly possible that anyone in the world would think is okay
for you to stand where I'm trying to deliver my baby and not only put my life I
raise but my child's life,
our risk.
So you not only stripped me of my dignity,
my respect,
my self worth,
but you're going to put my life in danger and my child life in danger.
So for me that was like a really hard part.
And then you know,
the correctional officer and the doctor was arguing because the doctor did
understand like,
you know,
this is my job,
this is,
this was her job to deliver the baby and make sure the mom and the baby was okay
and she couldn't do her job to the best of her abilities because of the
correction officer but not the I gave birth.
They automatically handcuffed you right away.
Like you don't really even have a moment to bond but your child not to feed
them,
not to just hold them and take in that precious moment.
And um,
at when you give birth,
they had seen to Westchester Medical Center.
So you are in a prison ward inside of Westchester Medical Center and then they
bring you there in a shock when you handcuff you and they may allow you to see
you judge howled maybe once or twice if you're lucky.
But in that process,
once again,
get shackled and you're handcuffed,
then it's the metal chain around your waist and this,
the handcuffs and it's that ankle shackles.
And then you brought into a wheelchair to see your child and they remove just
the handcuffs.
So you literally cannot walk with your child.
And all of these things are illegal at the time and no one is held accountable
for these things.
So as a k for us to be putting into the criminal justice system for breaking the
law,
but it's okay for Department of correction to break in day in and day out.
Why?
Because they do not value our lives.
Black girls,
women,
our lives are not valued,
not in society,
not in the current administrative system that we have right now.
Not inside a prison.
I will lives are not valued and it was just another reminder.
So at the,
I,
you know,
went through the whole process of being traumatized and humiliated and just I
thought like when I come home like I have to speak up.
Like,
cause if we don't speak up the ones who are being criminalized,
the ones who are being dehumanized and we don't speak up,
then who will like it's our stories were the ones who is experienced in these
horrific industries.
Just injustices all the time.
So I came home and I met with giant tomorrow who was at the Correctional
Association at the time and they came up to me and was like,
well,
where's you illegally shackled?
And I was like,
I was like,
I was so excited that,
you know,
there was something and there was organizations and people out there that cared
and were fighting it.
So I got involved and what we did,
we spoke to legislators at Albany,
we had letters,
we dealt with the media.
Um,
we did interviews and we rallies outside of the governor's office.
We fought and fought.
We made films about the experience of what we had to go through and we was able
to have this progressive law passed.
So we reinforced it 2000 the 2009 law.
And it also expanded it.
So your whole pregnancy,
you were not allowed to be shackled and handcuffed at all and you had the
privacy of not having to worry about a correctional officer being inside your
room.
I'll give him birth and it expanded so much.
And [inaudible] New York state now has the most progressive,
I'm anti shackling law in the country and it's because a woman directly
impacted,
you know,
speaking up in collaboration with allies and that would not have been possible
if it was not for the chances that we had to speak our piece and to make it
right and we have to continue to do this,
but any injustice that we witnessed or that we bear
[inaudible]
you for your work to Pico.
We are at this incredible moment around how finally it's a bipartisan
conversation on ending mass incarceration.
Finally,
we have Republicans and Democrats and in the public square talking about the war
on drugs was an egregious violation of human rights.
Finally,
we are saying that mass incarceration must end,
but the women who have been locked up,
who are still behind bars like Miss Alice are not part of these conversations.
What needs to happen in order to make sure that at this critical moment of
reform,
the women are not left behind?
Well,
what needs to happen is what's happening now.
You know,
um,
women like you
who are in these spaces who are making it necessary and a committing to this
work to allow us those who have been directly impacted to have our seat at the
table.
Our mantra at the council is nothing about us without us.
And so that's because as Andrea had said earlier,
we are the experts and how do you know what we need if you don't ask us and
engage us in changing these laws and these policies.
And as Miss Alice said,
you know,
I just want to reinforce that.
Like if not you then who you can't look to your neighbor or look to someone else
and say that it's their responsibility as humans in this,
in this world.
It is our responsibility and commitment to one another in order to make sure
that we are shifting this,
this disgusting criminal criminal justice system,
and to a more human justice system.
Yoshi,
I want to ask you as as we get ready to end this panel,
what,
what needs to happen to make sure that the stories,
the lived experience and expertise of women is part of our conversation on
racial justice?
I think before we even say when Nacy be happen,
I think we need to recognize and acknowledge what has been happening.
So women on the inside always played leadership roles.
They may change when change was needed and New York state,
I can speak for New York state and New York state women brought college back.
They had the first HIV peer education program,
which is model across the whole country.
They also had the children's center impairment and centers like these are the
kinds of things that women before coming out and then now they're out in a still
fighting.
So I feel like we just need to keep in mind like these are the women that we
need to have at the forefront.
These are the woman that had the experience and the expertise and these are the
woman that are going to be change agent to shift away from that Perpetual,
perpetual punishment paradigm.
To one of accountability,
transformation and Halan.
So,
um,
when I talked about this panel to some folks,
the response was,
well,
so where's the policy person or the lawmaker?
And I said,
right here,
right you all
are the ones that we need and we so desperately
really need your voices and we're,
we're deeply honored at Google to be able to have you here.
Thank you.
Hello everyone.
Hi,
my name is Markeesha.
Um,
I'm going to be doing a poem for you guys today.
it's called imprisoned and it's about more than just being in prison physically.
It's about being in prison motion emotionally and mentally.
So I'm,
here I go.
It's called in prison.
Okay.
Imprisoned in the dark and gloomy chamber.
I am in prison.
My feet chained together,
hands chain behind me.
I'm afraid of what might happen if I fight.
So I sit silently in prison and a dark and gloomy chamber.
I am in prisoned mouth taped shut,
so I can't scream.
I closed my eyes and sleep so I can dream in prison in the dark and gloomy
chamber.
I am in prison,
hands and feet chained together with suffering,
depression and doubt,
but it doesn't take much to break these chains and get out in prison in a dark
and gloomy chamber.
I am in prison.
Mouth taped shut with words.
I can't speak words like I am smart.
I am pretty words like released me.
No longer in prison and a dark and gloomy chamber.
No longer am I in prison.
I found the key to remove these tapes where my hands and feet.
I'm not afraid to fight you fear so don't challenge me.
No longer in prison in the dark and gloomy chamber.
No longer am I in prison.
Cut this tape from my mouth so I can scream and shout.
It's a great thing when you make a reality out of a dream.
No longer in prison and a dark and gloomy chamber.
No longer am I in prison.
I stand fearless.
No longer in prison and a dark and gloomy chamber.
I stand worthy.
I stand peaceful.
No longer in prison in this dark and gloomy chamber.
No longer am I in prison.
Thank you.
[inaudible]
hello everyone.
My name is Ana Kasparian.
I come from a news background.
I'm a reporter and host at the young Turks,
which is a very progressive online.
Yeah,
new show.
I just
want to take a minute to thank the organizers of this event for giving the
privilege to be here and to be part of this and also to be inspired by the
resilience of the women that we've already heard from.
And of course there are more women that we're going to hear from.
Uh,
in this portion of the event,
I am going to speak to an incarcerated woman,
Miss Santra Rucker and also her daughter Sindia Riley.
And it's more about the difficulty of establishing a relationship as a woman who
has been incarcerated due to this egregious justice system,
establishing a relationship with your family members,
with your children.
We've already heard about the number of women who are incarcerated and do have
young children and have a difficult time having a relationship with them as a
result of this.
So,
uh,
do we have a
okay.
Sorry.
Oh,
we're gonna start with,
okay.
That's great.
Uh,
so we're actually gonna start with kin Sindia,
Riley and Kindi of Riley's.
I apologize.
Sorry about that.
Um,
so,
okay.
Can we sit over there?
Okay,
great.
Okay.
Thank you so much for being here and having a conversation with me about
something that's so incredibly important and doesn't get talked about honestly
in the field of work that I do in journalism.
So tell me a little bit about your story.
What does it like establishing a relationship with your mother?
I know that she was given a life sentence when you were two years old.
Okay.
So,
um,
I'm,
both of my parents had been incarcerated with life sentences since I was two.
So it's kind of been like,
like a seesaw between trying to communicate with the,
both of them.
And I was raised underneath my grandparents.
So when my mother went to prison,
obviously it was either she gives me to somebody else or I'd be in a foster home
or just under the care of somebody else.
So she gave power of attorney to my grandparents and in that time it was as if
the right relationship between my mother and my father and I had been
transferred to my grandparents.
So it was as if they became my actual legitimate parents and the relationship
that you would typically have as a child where I would maybe talk to my mom and
individually or ride in a car.
It ceased to exist.
All of our holidays,
whether it's Christmas or birthdays or anything,
we had to go through it in a visiting room or it just,
we didn't ever had that physical relationship,
that caring and nurturing that there's just that availability for both of us to
sit down and be able to communicate thoroughly and adequately.
And I think that it's most effective when it comes to that actual like stable
relationship between the of you because no matter how much you talk on the phone
where you have 15 minute phone calls,
they cost $3 and you have 300 minutes a month.
The way that my father's visitation is set up is he can only get five visits a
month and out of 365 days,
that's just 60 visits a year.
So not only are we just restricted,
it's like we can never have a relationship with real sentimental value because
once my parents come home,
they don't truly know who I am and we have to sit and I guess take that and try
to build off of it.
And My mother has a release date now,
so it's six 2022 so it's about five or six years from now.
But when she comes home,
I'll be freshly graduated from college and it'll be the both of us sitting in a
room while I'm an adult and I'm a grown woman at this point and she's older and
we're trying to place ourselves in a situation where we're getting to know who
each other really truly is.
And it's kind of devastating for the both of us.
And it's practically traumatic because we had,
we don't know anything.
And the things that she should know from me being two or three and watching me
grow and watching what I like and what I love that's absent and I don't know
what she truly likes because even if it's,
it's not the same as if you're riding in a car with your parent and you sit down
and you hear a song and you say,
Oh,
I like this,
and she says she likes it too,
and then we can actually vibe and enjoy it together versus being on the
telephone and I say,
oh,
I like this and she agrees and it's just not the same.
I think a lot of times when we hear about incarceration and how we need to
reform our criminal justice system,
and it's always funny to me that it's called the justice system.
When there's such a lack of justice involved,
we don't really think about the impact it has on the family members of the
person who gets incarcerated.
Of course,
it's a massive injustice for the person who is incarcerated but also the family
members who are torn from their mothers and their fathers.
And so I came across an event that you actually spoke at where you talked about
the first time that you had physical contact with your mother.
And I thought that it was so incredible and it,
it shared a perspective that I don't think most people really know about.
So can you talk about that a little bit?
So I was speaking on,
I can't remember what event it was,
but once my,
my grandmother,
when I was younger,
she used to take me to all the different places and my mother was first in
Danbury,
Connecticut and we were living in Virginia.
So that was also not even the hike.
We had a fixed income as to Pico spoke of earlier.
So it was hard to travel hard to actually get that money to go there.
So mother's days we would go when I was young,
we would go when I was younger.
But when I became older it became a lot more difficult.
We had a lot more responsibilities and I hadn't,
I didn't realize and I,
um,
it was over this past summer that I went to go visit her in and I hadn't
realized that I hadn't seen my mother for 10 years.
And,
uh,
when I went to go visit her at,
the only thing I could remember was the smell of her hair and just sitting in
the visiting room,
seeing how happy and excited she wants to see me.
And then watching everything just unfold from the fact that the last time she
had actually seen me,
I was eight or nine years old and I was little,
I was innocent.
I hadn't been through all the,
like traumatic events in turmoil that I had a head,
um,
endured at that point.
So looking at her,
it was like looking at a complete stranger and I couldn't remember how she
looked and just looking at her and telling,
um,
like my aunt who had visited with me and just saying,
wow,
we really do look alike.
And just kind of looking into her eyes and thinking,
I've never seen you like pass the photograph or I've only,
I've never heard your voice constantly in front of me,
like actually going through my ears.
So other than through like the static of a telephone.
And I think sitting there and smelling her and just taking me back to the
innocence of my childhood and just remembering that I'm in this,
I was in the same exact predicament as I was then.
How has your experience with having an incarcerated mother impacted your future?
Because in every sense of the word,
you are a success story.
You have a successful academic career and you've persevered through what most
people would stereotype is something that's impossible.
Right?
So can you talk to me a little bit about that?
Um,
so I feel as though with the incarceration of both of my parents,
it,
it's embedded like a sense of determination within me.
That's kind of,
I feel like if I,
if they hadn't been incarcerated,
it wouldn't be as stable and there as it is because as when I was younger,
when I was in elementary school,
um,
they said that I had behavioral issues and it was maybe the,
I was in [inaudible],
which is a combination of first and second grade.
And I was,
I would act up,
I would threaten my teachers,
I would do all of the above.
And one day I wrote a letter to my teacher threatening her and they had to get a
police officer to come into the room and he had to tell me that threatening was
a felony and that it was what basically was just irrefutable,
you can't do that type of thing.
And my dean stopped and said,
you're so smart.
I don't understand why,
why are you doing it?
And I told him that I wanted to go with my parents and be with my parents and I
thought getting in trouble would place me in a situation where I go to prison
with the both of them.
And then he explained that it would either get me in juvenile detention or I'd
have to go to Merrimack,
which was the main institution of Virginia.
And from it was like that day forward,
I knew that there was like,
and it was physically impossible for me to be with them at all times and it just
set a standard for me and an expectation that if I couldn't just,
I naturally had the ability to do well.
So why not just do well for the sake of them or the sake of myself?
Because if I,
and like in this the way they,
the police officer,
he explained it and just saying how it's not the same.
I'm not going to be in a facility with them and it's not what I think it to be.
And just thinking of,
Oh,
I don't want to end up in that situation at all ultimately and just trying to be
better and set the stakes and let them know that they,
so they wouldn't have that burden where they know their child.
And I know it's a lot of blame can go on the parents while they're in prison for
what happens to the children while they're inside.
And I didn't want to be the one that ended up on the streets.
And my father,
when he was interviewed for humans in New York,
he said that I was the exception for a lot of his children.
And just the fact that,
um,
he said I had a brother that I didn't even know about that as soon as he was
gotten prison,
about a year later,
he ended up being killed because of following the footsteps of Him.
And he said,
it's children like me that should be the norm when they have an incarcerated
parent.
We should still be able to do well and still be able to excel and do things
differently.
So I feel like my future's impact because it gives me a role and it gives me not
only,
um,
which I've kind of found my voice because of Topeka.
I've found my voice truly and honestly,
because I had never spoke about it until I came to a point where I was so
destitute.
And by myself and alone and I was just hurting and it was everybody that my
grandmother had left me with had passed away.
So I was 18 living by myself about to go to college.
I was like,
there was no one to take me.
No one helped me with that transition.
And it just got to a point where I had nothing.
I didn't have any money.
And it grew to the point where I had to go and do everything by myself.
So when Topeka came and said,
hey,
would you like to speak on a panel about how it affects you?
I never really thought about how it majorly impacted my life and kind of I was
numb to it and it was just,
I was so succumb to feeling,
oh this like everything was normal.
Oh,
I'd go visit them,
a visitor rooms.
I talked to them on the phone.
It was just seeing my vulnerability and then realizing that every single time I
spoke it was like I was learning something different about myself.
So I feel like from an educational standpoint,
it shows that you can practically do anything and like,
um,
to be cassette early,
I do a lot of stuff with grace so it makes me feel like I'm powerful that um,
I'm invincible and it makes,
it really takes me to a point where it just because you don't have your parents,
you still have that ability to do better and go beyond when anybody can tell you
that you can't do
amazing.
So I just wanted to quickly note on the young Turks,
we often bring up the issue of white privilege,
which you know,
unfortunately some of our audience members get very offended about.
And the reason why I'm bringing that up right now is because these are the types
of obstacles that you know,
the disenfranchise have to persevere through in order to become success,
right?
These are the issues that I think a lot of people don't realize occur that we
have a bias justice system,
that we have certain obstacles for certain communities that people like me don't
ever have to worry about.
And that's the reason why I feel that it's important for someone like me to be
an ally and hear stories like yours and,
and do what I can to fight to reform the justice system that we have right now.
If there's one final thing that you would want everyone to know about how all of
this has impacted you and your relationship with your family,
what would it be?
So I think,
and especially over the last couple of days,
that just separating a mother from her daughter or a father from our daughter,
it's really just rifting.
And like I said earlier,
it's really numbing where you get to this point that you want to know each other
so well and it seems so impossible because there's so many physical limitations
and monetary and just,
it's just so much stuff where it takes you away from it really ever.
Having that capability to establish a real physical relationship.
And just the idea that if you're arguing,
if you're sad or you're having just a debate or just a bad day,
there is no way that you can just hop up and say,
I'm going to go visit my mom.
You have to sit on the phone.
And then from every single penny of every second you're talking,
it's going to either go to waste or go to a really good cause of talking on the
phone.
And I think more like lately with my mother,
it's been,
we have such limited time but,
and like it's like we're going and talking back and forth and battling about
what we know about each other and what we don't.
And just to sit back and think,
if you are home,
we wouldn't have to do this.
Or to think about other daughters that might not have the majority that I have
or might not have that ability to even talk.
And I just think that it's unfair to the children and it's just unfair to all of
us are anybody who can sit and allow a parent to not be able to be with their
child in some sense or just not to think about every single stipulation that
surrounds being with their child and just thinking if you took yourself,
if you have a child yourself and you take yourself and separate them and put
them in a room and you guys are just divided by these four walls and you have no
way of communicating with each other without her sliding a dollar under the door
or $5 for a limited amount of time and just thinking about how you could build
that relationship or how that could taint you and it's just not,
I don't think that when they're making the policies and the legislation around
it,
they don't think about us as the children.
They think about the crime,
but they don't put in place that you're hurting us as well.
While my mom's in prison,
that puts me in prison too,
so it's not just affecting them.
We both have to live it together and simultaneously,
thank you so much for sharing your
story.
I appreciate it.
Uh,
leaves the stage.
I want to acknowledge that not only is can be a powerful,
fierce woman advocate for so many other girls and boys who's parents are behind
bars,
but can,
he is also a sophomore at the University of Virginia
[inaudible]
majoring in chemistry and minoring in astronomy.
So,
so we,
you know,
because it's our commitment to bring in the voices of the women behind bars
where we have a little bit of time before we can bring candy as mom in through
the phone.
We can't do it until two 10.
So before,
uh,
we bring candy mom,
onto the car.
I'm going to do two things.
I'm going to ask Andrea James to join the stage with Kendzia and Anna to help
represent a while.
We're waiting for Sandra Rucker to join us to talk about more the experience of
being a mother behind bars and that mother child bond,
which as an a pointed out is rarely talked about,
right?
When we have these conversations around the criminal justice system.
So I invite you on,
Anna.
Thank you for going with the flow horror.
It's my pleasure.
And,
and before you all get started on that conversation,
there are these pictures that had been flashing on the screens and these
pictures are remarkable paintings done by women and girls behind bars as part of
an organization known as artistic noise.
It's a New York based organization that goes into our correctional facilities,
adult and juvenile and gives young women and men and boys and girls and our
elders the chance to have art in their lives as an opportunity to express their
emotions,
their pain and their joy.
So I want to acknowledge these beautiful paintings that artistic noise has
allowed us to share with you.
So I think it's also important to maybe focus a little bit on,
you know,
the types of laws like the war on drugs and,
and you know,
some of the influences behind those types of policies that lead to individuals
being incarcerated for ridiculous reasons.
Um,
so since I come from a news background and do a lot of reporting on the justice
system and also policies that politicians propose,
there are a lot of financial interests at play that,
that force,
not force but influence politicians to push for sentencing.
Uh,
that's incorrect,
incredibly harsh related to drug policy or for mandatory minimums,
things like that.
And so it's not,
it's not an accident.
What we're seeing in our justice system is a direct influence of things like
money and politics of private prisons in,
you know,
encouraging our representatives to pass legislation that would incarcerate
people for profit.
And so I don't want anyone to think that,
hey,
these are people who are just,
you know,
tough on crime.
It's not being about tough on crime.
It's about victimizing people to make a dollar.
And,
and I think that that's an important issue that everyone needs to focus on.
The,
the women that we've heard from today are not criminals.
These are innocent individuals who have been victimized by an injust justice
system were unjust,
I should say justice system.
So I can't help but share my opinion.
I don't,
I,
no one told me that I should or if I could,
but I can't help myself because this is something that I'm very passionate about
and I really do want reform here anyway.
Uh,
so thank you for joining us,
Andrea.
Um,
so talk to me a little bit about your experiences.
I,
you've been working in this line of work for a long time and I think it's so
incredibly important.
Can we talk a little bit more about the positive impacts that,
you know,
women such as yourself have had,
uh,
in this,
in this space?
Well,
sure.
I want to dial back just a little bit just so we can,
just so we can touch upon the issues that can dia was talking about because as
a,
as a woman who taught,
so I was a lawyer who was sentenced to serve a 24 month sentence in the federal
prison for women in Danbury,
Connecticut.
Okay.
I was allowed to self report.
I was a lawyer.
We were treated differently.
I showed up in court twice,
wants to hear the charges against me and the other two here.
What I was going to be sentenced to.
I negotiated my sentence down from 63 months to 24 months and I went off and uh,
serve my 24 months.
I happen to have older adults,
children at the time,
but I also had a 12 year old daughter who's currently a sophomore at Spelman
university,
Spelman College.
And I also had a baby boy who I had just given birth to who when I walked into
that prison.
So my whole family took me to the prison.
I again was treated differently than 99% of the women that I was incarcerated
with.
Uh,
who had not seen their children since they were looking out the back window of a
law enforcement vehicle and watching their babies being shuttled away by some
other state actor.
Okay.
And then I was in a prison with women who had not seen their children for six,
seven,
eight years if they had seen them at all since they had been incarcerated.
And the feeling of what that's like,
I,
you know,
my baby boy was five months old.
I did not come home until he was two.
This is Sandra calling in.
So I'm happy that cause I want to hear her voice and not mine.
Uh,
but those are the very real things that women who are incarcerated are dealing
with and not even being able to breathe.
I want to leave us with this point that for a woman who leaves her children
behind,
we literally have to put our children on a shelf in order to breathe to get
through our sentence.
That is criminal.
Okay.
Yes.
Okay,
great.
Uh,
my name is Ana Kasparian.
Thank you for taking the time to speak with me.
Oh,
thank you.
Thank you for allowing me.
So we were just having a great conversation with your daughter about some of the
obstacles to,
you know,
establishing a bond between the two of them.
And you know,
we heard her side of the story,
her perspective and I was hoping that we can also hear your perspective as well.
Okay.
Well the dynamic is like the dynamics of being an incarcerated.
It's really sensitive when it comes to a mother and daughter relationship
because
you don't want your child to have any type of resentment or anger because she
feels abandoned or whatever the situation is due to my circumstances.
And that'd be the come to prison.
Do you know?
These are the things that I hope,
but you know,
people might feel that it's wrong for me to say.
Like I'm not really remorseful
for the things that led me to come to prison.
In fact,
I think that the greater gravity was my choice and my poor choices at the time.
I didn't think of those choices that those choices would affect my children or
my family because I was doing the things that I love to do at the time.
So at the same time,
I don't want to beat myself up for my past to make my relationship better with
my daughter because I can't change the past,
you know?
So what I'm doing is I'm trying to benefit from it from the past and move on.
But in my own beliefs up,
I believe that Karma plays a big part and the condition of my imprisonment
because that's my personal belief,
but at the same time I believe that whatever you are and whatever you are not,
you earn it whether it's good or bad and whatever you are or whatever you are,
not you.
This call is from a seat,
a little cousin,
and right now I feel like I have changed dramatically and not have inclined
raise my level of consciousness to a higher vibration.
So what did I can be able to be active with my daughter to show love for my
daughter,
to do the things not trying to make up for my past with the things that a mother
would do.
I tried to do these things over the phone,
30 emails through visitation,
sending things to my daughter to show her that I love her and that I am sorry to
not be there.
So in my absence I do things but my heart
a little bit about what it was like to have physical contact with you for the
first time.
I'm curious to hear what that felt like for you
because you don't know
what to say.
Like,
I want it to be a mother,
but I didn't want to act too over protective because of my absence due to my
absence.
But I wanted to show her that.
Yeah,
true.
I am your mother and I want you to be open with me.
I want you to understand me,
and I want you to learn who I am through visitation.
Because we only would talk over the phone.
And it was kind of a bonding time where I looked at her and she looked at me
and,
but at the same time,
I didn't know what to say.
I didn't know if I should touch her.
I didn't know if she would reject me.
So I watch how other people in a visitation with their children.
So does,
I can learn that,
okay,
this is our right to hold that in.
This is our right to do this.
Well,
this is our rights to do that.
But it was pretty,
it was more emotional for me when I came back because I would like,
I wish I would've said this.
I wish I would have said that.
And when she came to visit me,
my other family was there,
my sister and my nephew.
So it's kind of,
I couldn't be as personal as I wanted to be,
let's say the things that I really wanted to because it was so long.
It was,
it had been 10 years before I said before,
I say my family and my daughter.
So it was really hard.
It's even harder when you have to come back from visitation
to be around total strangers that you don't love and that you don't know,
you know?
So I'm sorry,
can you hear me?
Yes,
I can hear you.
Thank you so much for sharing your story.
It's,
it's through several members of the audience that are in tears right now over
your,
what you're saying.
Um,
so India has done incredible things with her life.
She is a sophomore at the University of Virginia.
She's studying,
you know,
majors that I can't even wrap my brain around.
She's an incredible young woman.
And so what are your feelings about that?
I wonder if my hat made her life better because she was raped,
raped by the same parents as me.
That's my mom the day.
So I know,
I knew she would be a good person,
a loving person.
You know what,
I'm glad.
I feel like she's the better side of me.
You know?
Like I feel like I could make it and I didn't make it and I wasn't successful.
Like I want this to be,
I see good that with her doing it,
it makes me feel proud because she is,
she's a part of me,
you know?
And I knew that she would do great things and I just always knew that she has,
she has great potentials,
so I wasn't shocked that she would be as productive and intelligent as she is
and everything that she says play in,
you know?
So I knew that he would be all right,
But I often wonder if I was home to raise her,
which she has taken that route,
you know?
Oh,
maybe my poor choices would have incepted her and affected her,
you know?
So I was Kinda glad to be asked then in a way so that she could have the perfect
life.
You shared with us that you fortunately finally have a release date.
And so I'm curious what you maybe fantasize about doing with your family doing
with India when you are released.
Well,
a lot of tops I see other subtle,
a lot of prisoners that lead,
they make big plans and the oldest seem to be somewhere lost in the attic when
they get home.
But I know one of the biggest problems that my family faith is financial
problems.
So I've been into your studying how to learn the different grants that's
available when I get out the different loans that they have were convicted felon
and try to use those things.
Please open up a restaurant where my family could benefit from.
And I think that financing is a great important for everybody in life because
without money you can't really do anything.
And I believe that we can come together as a family and be productive and to
have fun and go places and travel and do the things not to make up for lost
time,
but for the now,
you know.
And so I hope to have a restaurant when I get out.
I took call an area art and I told Kenya how to bake over the telephone.
So I'm hoping that I could do that,
not just for myself but for my family.
You know,
that's one of the main things and I just want to be,
I just want to be a mother to my daughter and those things I have tried to do
from prison,
you know,
which I have great limitations here,
but I believe when I get home it could be better.
Would it be pissed on my daughter because of my daughter,
daughter feels bad at her.
Well,
she feels any resentment or she feels any anger towards my absence,
then it's going to be quite difficult for me to do the things that I would love
to do and have been a great desire to do.
But it has to be a mutual agreement.
And I just hope to be the most successful person that I can be.
I want to be the person that I wasn't in 1999 before I came to prison.
So I have high goals,
I have high standards,
I have high principal,
and I believe that with God being in my life,
that these,
these things are manifested in before I even come home,
you know,
so I'm not waiting for the manifestation that take place when I walk out the
door.
Um,
I'm preparing it now through my provisions,
through my prayers and through what I know,
which is my belief.
But I believe that we were all one and we'll be one.
It's Kinda hard to be one from prison because of the barricades that we say,
but hopefully I hope that through my mom and dad,
that the love that they instilled in me,
the human compassion that they instilled in me,
that they instilled those things to pick India.
So when I get home,
everything will be as if I never left.
And that's how I would like it.
That's how I would want it to be.
One I touched,
you know,
home,
I'm sorry I get on the way.
Emotional.
What she knows.
I'm sorry.
No,
go ahead.
Yeah,
but you know,
I understand where I am.
I understand the circumstances of my life and they've visited,
took shape to get me here and the people who are gravitated to,
but doing that era of the eighties that was like the end thing.
This call is from the seat of the prison.
What was happening in that it's hot and the decision set up made were what were
good decision.
It was just normal and typical for people my age in that area.
Sorry to interrupt you.
I just want to let you know that we might lose you soon and if we do,
I just want to thank you for your time and thank you for speaking with us and
sharing your story.
No,
and I thank you for allowing me.
I thank you for having human compassion to be able to be attentive audience to
this like this as a shift of awareness and note it.
I just know everything is going to be all right just from speaking to y'all.
And I think you all can make a big difference.
And I thank you again.
I really do because you haven't influential power that can change a lot and just
from the audience being there today,
this shows that everybody,
destiny and their destiny and fate can change and you could be really
influential in a carriage and two prisoners as well because it's difficult.
It's very difficult,
difficult for our children and for us as prisoners.
But I thank you as well.
Sorry I'm crying.
Do you have no reason to apologize?
Please take care of yourself and thank you again.
You
who Google where working at Google is like understanding jazz that,
you know,
somebody's been here some as we've been there.
So this is awesome.
This is a very googly because this is very much like an act of jazz.
Um,
I know that it's,
it's a lot to hold all of the,
the ways in which we are bearing witness and being proximate to what the costs
of incarceration has been to our mothers and our daughters.
But I think it's important to stay present because it's not only an issue of
placing and over criminalizing and relegating our women and mothers to
incarceration.
It is also a narrative of what is happening to our girls and there's a lot of
conversation around the school to prison pipeline,
but there's not conversation around how the girls fit into that pipeline and how
in many ways the girls have a separate pipeline into the juvenile justice
system.
We wanted this panel to be able to surface some of the lived experiences and the
lived expertise around what is happening to our girls.
So if we could start with charity,
if you could each introduce yourselves and then we'll talk.
Yes.
Hello everyone.
My name is charity Chandler Cole.
I am a social justice advocate and I advocate for various social justice issues
such as criminal justice reform,
human sex trafficking and foster care and I sit on various boards and committees
throughout the state that addressed these issues.
Hi,
I'm going to have to know,
my name is Michelle [inaudible] for the task force on an ending course
incarceration in New York City for [inaudible].
Hi,
my name is Sarah.
I'm actually also part of the task force and I'm also,
I'm working at the [inaudible] Institute of Justice in New York City.
So beginning with charity.
If you could each talk about how you were placed into the juvenile justice
system and your experiences there.
There.
Absolutely.
So at the age of 10 my mother was going through a divorce and she got breast
cancer at the same time and she pretty much afterwards went through a state of
depression,
stress and anxiety.
And she basically just gave up on the six children she had.
And we kind of had to fend for ourselves.
My older sister in at the juvenile justice and foster care system at the age of
12 so when I was 14 I was the big sister.
I was the mother and I did everything I could to provide for my four younger
siblings while we were on welfare at the age of 16 I got caught stealing
underwear from Ross.
Nothing cute.
It was Haynes,
you know,
from a siblings.
So it was,
you know,
simply out of a peer desire of need for my family.
And the police caught him,
my mother to pick me up and she said take her to jail.
And they did.
And my mom at the time use the foster care system and juvenile justice system to
kind of one by one,
you know,
get rid of the children that she no longer desire to have.
At the time.
It wasn't because she just didn't love us.
She just didn't know how to take care of us any longer after you know what she
experienced.
I um,
from there,
after there,
I spent the next two years in and out of juvenile hall and foster care.
No one at any point ask my mother,
why do you want your child to go to jail?
You know,
why is she stilling underwear?
What situation is happening in your family to cause your daughter to,
you know,
still underwear?
Um,
here are some alternatives to incarceration.
I was just,
you know,
they said,
okay.
They hung up the phone,
they handcuffed me and put me in the back of their patrol car book to me and
took me to juvenile hall.
I at that very moment realize that my life had zero value and that I could
easily be discarded and put away my experience in the juvenile justice system
and the foster care system were horrid and I experienced and was exposed to
things I probably would have never experienced,
you know,
living in the streets and in gang infested and drug infested neighborhood I any
ounce of self esteem and confidence I have when out the window and I was
constantly degraded.
I felt enslaved and I was psychologically abused and sexually exploited while in
the fall in the system.
And because of what I experienced and because of the filling of,
you know,
abandoning the four siblings that needed me,
who was going to feed them and take care of them,
who's going to walk them to school the next day,
just filming,
you know,
completely just abandoned alone and worthless.
I left the system,
determine that I was going to work my ass off for the rest of my life to help
change it.
Okay.
Um,
well everything has led to one,
almost 13.
Amani 20.
Um,
I came here,
I did notice,
speak English at all and my mother was working seven days a week.
Um,
and,
um,
the only person that I knew it was my mother and they,
nobody else.
When I went to school,
I,
my,
my school class was only Spanish,
so I didn't need it really learn English at all.
And when I was going to school,
I was shy.
I didn't talk to the other kids.
And then one time I just went to Mcdonald's and I met this guy and you know,
like he was much older than me,
keeping in mind that I was only 13 and you're like,
uh,
he talked to me and you know,
like I say,
my mother was never time.
No,
never had the time to be with me.
And I,
the reason why I moved to new to United,
it was because I wanted to have the mother and daughter relationship because my
mother all the time she was working.
And,
um,
and then this guy who,
you know,
treat me right,
quote unquote,
who pay attention to me,
make me,
uh,
being in the idea of been in love.
And one time,
um,
you know,
like I was going crazy,
the only person that I really pay attention to and once I,
we just went to the mall and like,
he stole a tee shirts from JC penny,
25 bucks and you know,
um,
we got caught and you know,
he was like,
oh,
Michelle,
take charge,
take charge.
They're not going to do nothing to you.
You're underage.
And I was like,
no,
it's not my full.
And he's like,
oh,
he's a argument with me.
And of course you don't want to be mad with the purse.
You don't want the person to be mad at you,
the only person who's paying attention to you.
So I said,
yeah,
I take the charge and then I will spend an eye,
uh,
the person.
And then my mother came,
took me into the next day,
I run away and went back to him and he like,
this was like,
um,
family core and my lawyer was like,
oh,
just Michelle,
just take the charge is going to be 18 months of probation.
And of course,
you know,
like I did not know nothing.
I didn't speak English.
My lawyer was um,
only speak English.
So it was really,
really hard.
The interpreter was there only for like two minutes.
And I was like,
yeah,
sure,
whatever.
Um,
and then I wanting me to another stop missing school.
I got pregnant at 15,
I was in seventh grade and you're like,
oh,
this thing crash.
I,
I run away,
got a warrant.
Then I,
uh,
violation of probation went back cause I always wanted to do the right thing.
I always want it to be somebody but never,
nobody asked me why I was doing what I was doing,
what I wanted to be,
where am I going,
what is my future?
Right.
And at the end I went back,
I try,
I try to do things right but there was no support at all.
And you know,
I was a teenage mom and I Japan drop out of middle school and every graduated
and I just,
I couldn't take it any longer.
And I,
my probation officer by me again,
I ran away.
Then the judge said that I was a runner and he put me in a secure facility in
New York and I spent like a pie a six to eight months in there.
And after that I went to the um,
a group home close to home,
you know,
secure facility.
And I was uh,
it was when it starts to speak in English was when I was in this secure facility
cause nobody speaks Spanish over there.
But I could,
I could put together the images,
what I see,
what I hear and it was amazing.
But you know,
like at the first time when I was there I couldn't eat.
Why?
Because I didn't like the food.
Like I just,
I couldn't take it.
Nobody want there.
How he lost 10,
20 pounds in a month over there.
And you know,
like,
um,
when I got out,
I spend like two months in a group home,
but I was always scared,
you know,
like people talk about Rikers island is secure facility and how bad it is.
And I was like,
damn,
I don't want to go there.
I was so afraid because at that time I didn't have papers at all.
And,
and then I was like,
if I do something and then was this girl,
she was 15 and tried to fight me and I was like,
I can't get into her cause you know,
like,
what is next?
Next thing you know,
I'm going to get deported.
I can't do that.
Have a child and I want something,
I want to do something with my life.
And then I got moved to the foster care system where,
you know,
um,
I spent about two years in there and I met this amazing work and then I made my
mentor and everything started being put in together,
went to school,
got my GED,
and then like when I was going to school,
it's when I see when I got to sit down with people that has been decades of
their life and press them in how much they stuff for.
And then I will ask them,
why you don't do something about it?
Looping like,
no,
they're waiting for the other person.
And then I decided to be that person and you know,
um,
if there's one thing that I will,
that I have to go back to,
I wouldn't change it even though I would love to have been for my daughter or
this time,
but I am where I am because I,
everything that I had done and I'm liking myself,
I'm starting to love myself.
I'm just listening to,
to you ladies.
I mean it's just echoing the same thing that,
you know,
um,
I was 14 the first time that I was involved with the system and I mean I was in
the back of the police car or 14 years old handcuff because of a fight that
happened at home.
And um,
you know,
my parents,
I mean they stay together,
they're still together today and you know,
coming from Long Island,
which is a suburban community,
um,
you know,
that's not something that is the norm there.
So parents are limited resources on what to have.
Like what do you do when your child is out of control or what do you do when you
know your kid is skipping school?
And in that case,
the cops were called and I was placed in handcuffs and the whole ride at 14,
too.
I didn't even know where I was going.
And I went,
I ended up getting taken to the family court and that there was a petition
filed,
a pins petition at the time.
And it was just so chaotic that I had no idea what was happening.
I just thought,
well,
I must have committed a crime.
Must've done something wrong because I'm in the back of this car.
And that just continued on from age 14 on until 18.
And I just kept going back and forth to court.
Also in school,
I was considered homeless because I didn't live at home and I was actually
kicked out of three different high schools and it was very chaotic.
And people,
um,
in the school district didn't understand why I was acting out.
I was disrupting class.
It was disrupting everything that came into my path.
I just destroyed it because I didn't have any support at home and everything
seemed,
it was fine from the outside,
but no one was asking those questions to find out what was really going on.
And there was,
at the time,
there is a probation officer's station in the school district and she would,
you know,
full uniform school resource officers,
what they're called now.
And she would come to class and make sure I was in class and all my classmates
thought that I was a problem.
No one wanted to hang out with me.
Um,
you know,
my friends,
their parents wouldn't allow them to hang out with me because I was a problem
child.
So that continued and eventually I ended up in independent living.
So when I turned 16,
I was eligible to go to this group home with other girls.
And,
um,
I started experimenting with drugs.
I was smoking weed.
I mean I just wanted some kind of escape,
like some kind of release because I didn't have any,
I didn't feel any connection to anyone,
not even to myself.
So,
you know,
and then family core,
going back and forth to court during that time,
the legal aid who was supposed to be representing me didn't ask me,
what do you want?
What's going on or what's going on at home or where do you want to go?
So I just kind of cycled through the system.
And when I aged out at 18,
there was no,
um,
plan.
Like there was no nowhere for me to go.
It was just like,
well,
you're,
you've aged out of this system and now we're just going to leave you to your own
devices.
And what ended up happening was because I had no relationship with my family
that wasn't reconciled all those years from 14 to 18,
um,
I ended up moving in with a boyfriend of mine.
And by the time I turned 19,
actually seven years to the day,
I was arrested for my part in a robbery and I was tried as an adult and I served
time in jail.
And,
um,
it's just been,
it's,
you know,
that all those missed opportunities from when I was younger.
And it just seems so simple now when I look back on it,
that all somebody had to do was ask me what is going on with you?
Or how can we help you?
Or how can we support you?
And that simple question could have changed the trajectory of my whole life.
And it's just been such a struggle now from being a girl and now being an adult
woman with this felony conviction.
And it's been so challenging to find a job.
And,
and you know,
I'm not representative of the population of girls that are in the system.
I mean,
it disproportionately affects women and girls of color.
And I feel like it's a responsibility that I have.
And then I hope that those listening and those here today can understand that
like we have a responsibility to speak out about it because that's the only way
that we're going to change the hearts and minds of people that can make
decisions.
And um,
yeah.
So it's just been challenging.
And if we can change things from the front door,
which is the girl system,
then that would help
[inaudible] talk
about this piece more that each of you has given voice to have.
Nobody asked me what was going on and I've spent many,
many moments,
hours
and days in girls correctional facilities.
And I remember the first time I went,
I thought,
my gosh,
they're just girls.
They're just hurt,
abused,
violated girls.
Right?
Hey,
I want to understand better.
Can you help me to understand better?
Why is it that the system feels so comfortable just putting the girls behind
bars then asking that question of what's going on?
Well,
I think for girls,
um,
just overall we're just looked at differently in the criminal justice system.
Um,
people fail to realize that,
you know,
when we have fanned,
it's normally because of something we experienced in our life prior to the
offense.
Either through,
you know,
bad parenting or poverty or lack of education are being abused in that when we
offend,
it's usually out of survival.
So it's usually something we've stolen our,
you know,
we've acted out or because we were actually victims of something such as,
sex trafficking or exploitation or even domestic violence.
And when they look at us as women,
because as,
even as girls,
we still are,
are nurturers.
We still help to provide for our family and for siblings.
So when we have fanned versus when boys a fan,
we should have known better and we deserve the punishment we received as opposed
to boys.
Oh,
they're just youthful at immature.
And when we are charged for our fences where,
you know,
ours are gender specific offenses versus,
and so,
um,
because there are gender specific offensives we're perceived differently and
judged differently and treated differently once we're in the criminal justice
system because what gets sets in jail versus what gets boys in jail,
they don't really know how to,
to deal with that.
So they just look at us as being,
you know,
just,
we're just bad or where we're acting out or where it were whores because we were
sexually exploited or wherever the case.
So we should be treated as such instead of realizing that,
you know,
we're,
we're more vulnerable,
where more fragile,
we,
we need more help because we're susceptible more susceptible to violence and to
be treated being treated differently.
So it's just a totally different lens because of what we're,
you know,
because of our offenses is,
is different and we often go to jail for nonviolent offenses and we get these
crazy ridiculous charges for something that's minimal and something that had
someone taking the time to say,
you know,
what's going on?
Why are you 14 in jail for prostitution?
You know,
the first thing I saw when I went to juvenile hall,
even though that wasn't my charge,
was that there are so many girls in here locked up for having sex with adult
men.
I was blown away and at no point did anyone say,
you know what?
What's happening?
You're being exploited or being victimized.
No,
they were criminalized and we're constantly being criminalized for that.
We should be looked at as you know,
ways to help us in.
That's just not happening.
Well I do believe the people don't get to the roof of the causes of the
problems.
You know,
like we put,
let's say we have taught who are the real expertise on these.
Like is it a book who's going to teach you?
Like what is it going to be about in there?
And no,
of course now we need to put the youth.
We need to put the people,
nothing about us without us.
You know who,
who are the ones who are going to come up with a solution because we experienced
what is the problem.
And of course all we have all this amazing people that come here that goes to
the dissertation centers or whatever and they have no idea.
They don't know what it's like to be there.
Um,
and most importantly,
the people that come up with ideas are go,
go to these places.
And you know,
like when you're in that facility,
we have seen people be treated differently.
People,
kids who have been intimidated by the staff and you know,
like when you are in a facility once a month,
the ones,
whatever you need,
the staff are there for safety reasons.
But you don't,
you are you able to speak Fridley?
Of course now.
Why?
Because you don't like you get there and you leave.
No,
I'm stayed there and if I say something wrong,
what it's going to happen next.
Um,
I just wanted to make a point that,
you know,
a status offense.
So I was when I was actually detained,
like I a status offense is something,
it's not a crime and it's when you're,
um,
it should because of your status as a minor that the action becomes
criminalized.
And that's what happened.
That's how I started.
And I became involved with the system running away from home and skipping
school.
I was placed in handcuffs and I was placed in a detention facility in a jail
cell because I skipped school.
And I think people don't realize that that's what we do here.
I mean,
if we really take a hard look at the practices and the policies that we have
that affect girls and,
and just all kids in general,
like we should not be locking up kids for skipping school.
And,
um,
you know,
that experience and like,
and not asking children are cause that's what we're talking when we're talking
about children,
what dry the reasons behind their actions are.
And um,
you know,
I remember just being the only girl in the facility and I was spending a lot of
times,
I mean isolated.
Um,
because like we need to be separated from the boys.
And just there's always this notion to protect girls and we need all this
protection.
And that was not helpful because the protection that's offered as punitive and
it,
it's,
it really damaged the rest of my,
you know,
my trajectory.
So I think it's important to listen and there are a lot,
there was a lot of assumptions that are made,
I think a different system points when you're in court.
The assumption is made by the judge that the legal aid has talked about this
with the kid or with the child and that's not what
happened to me.
So,
um,
yeah,
I think we just need to just start implementing that every system point.
Can I add something to it?
Um,
so I do believe that we are being put in,
in the menu in that,
in the table.
Um,
yeah.
Menu and not at the table.
Yeah.
Um,
unfortunately,
uh,
what could be a whole day of conversation on girls and we need to have a whole
day on conversations around girls because of the systematic negligence that is
being shown to our girls.
Um,
we have to,
to give the stage over to cap black and mally chacan but I went as so deeply
thank you for being the young women,
the young,
fierce warrior advocates for other girls who are behind bars.
Thank you so much.
Yeah.
Hello.
I'm,
I just wanted to thank you guys so much for inviting me to introduce our next
speaker.
My name is Kat and I had been a youtuber since I was a young teenager.
Um,
youtube has been a very central place in,
in my life and it's really been where I've always come to express the things
that have happened in my life and um,
the good,
the bad and the ugly.
Um,
and unfortunately while I had my platform,
I experienced sexual violence and
okay,
he has,
youtube had been such a,
an integral part of my life.
It was where I turned to express my trauma and that didn't go very well.
I was told almost immediately that I had made up the story that I told the story
for views that I had fabricated it because after all,
who would want to rape someone like me?
And so I internalized that I deleted my videos and for really long time I didn't
talk about it.
But once I gained the strength to speak about it again,
I realized just how much rape and sexual violence is a tool of silence.
Just how much it is used against women and people in general to silence them and
to stop them from being able to get justice.
That rape culture relies on this silence.
And that social media especially is an amazing place for us to be able to come
forward and speak.
And when I started telling my story,
I got contacted by women who had similar stories,
who said that my story reflected theirs and we all said to each other the words
that we all needed to hear so badly that we believed you.
So social media has been a very important part of my,
my activism and what I do.
Um,
we've seen so many good positive things come out of raising voices and,
um,
a lot of the women today,
there's that spoke our leading leaving me wanting to have conversations on my
platform to draw attention to a lot of the things that I didn't about,
um,
were happening to our women and girls.
Um,
our next speaker is going to be married Yukon,
who is a woman who is,
he has been using her poetry to fight against,
um,
women who are being,
who are being trafficked.
Um,
so I just wanted to introduce ImageCon.
Okay.
Hi Guys.
Um,
so yeah,
I was traffic that 12th.
Um,
thank you.
so I wrote this poem when I was 13 years old.
I just wanted to give you guys a mind frame of where I was,
um,
at the time and my walking through hill or beneath the shadows of death.
I need someone to help me.
I'm like a baby crying for nipple,
like a dog wanting it to owner,
beautiful on the outside,
but he'll degraded,
misusing ugly on the inside.
Why?
No?
Why no one loved me.
For me pushing people away because they act as if they care,
like to park with his mistress.
Love affair have a soulless steel,
uh,
hardest.
Lindsay has a bird's feather,
like a tiger hunting for prey,
but a mind frame of a baby cut on the level of a great boat and have a spark out
of this road.
And I have dreams,
but what is that?
I want to help people because I need help or reach out to people because no one
reached out to me.
I'm living alone with no honesty and existing in this role with no dignity.
They say,
I have a purpose,
but what might that be?
I want to be like sleeping beauty,
healthfully,
wake up in someone else's body.
That's not me.
I keep asking who might that be wanting to be like pink,
how she's so energetic and so sleep like Jim Murray crying like a puppy acting
out like Angelina Jolie,
Mr and Mrs. Smith beating myself up.
Not me,
but inside of me
they say I act out because of my ADHD.
I'm going to be me learning to set up like a baby.
Better yet trying to come out of cocoon hopefully one day or maybe picking that
cheese like a baby mice,
like a cage bird screaming for food.
Is it bad that mark mine six the gates of hell or wonders for a black night?
Why can't I have someone hold me tight?
I look at my reflection and yet my body starts to feel cold like a polar bear
and winter.
But a vampire.
You're at night,
Katrina washing people away and I'm trying to find a secret.
Get away.
Thank you.
Wow.
Um,
thank you Molly for sharing your words.
You know,
the poem speaks for itself,
but I just,
I feel so incredibly privileged to be in this room and thank all of you for
sharing your stories.
Um,
just that we're so privileged to have you here at Google today.
For those of you that I haven't met,
my name is Matthew for him and I'm a program manager@google.org which is the
philanthropic arm of Google and I support our racial justice work.
So I've been incredibly moved by everything I've heard today.
Um,
and also reminded of sort of where we've started this work is Google and how far
it's come.
So I,
I wanted to share a little bit of that story and in reflect back to when we
began our racial justice funding at Google back in 2014 and we were to be
honest,
curiously optimistic about where it would lead.
Um,
like many folks in the room,
there are definitely Googlers who have been impacted by the system of mass
incarceration who have parents and family members who are incarcerated today.
And many of these Googlers advocate and volunteer with criminal justice
organizations in their personal time.
But working on the giving team at Google,
uh,
we were trying to,
to move this issue to the center of our companies consciousness and to,
to bring it to a place where we could open that conversation to those who may
not feel as proximate to the issue.
And so I remember the day that my colleague Justin Steele got the signal from
our executives to present our initial work in this area at our company meeting.
And Malika referenced it at the beginning of our,
of our day.
Um,
but it's,
it's a,
it's a big meeting.
Um,
Googlers from all over the world.
Tune in on Gvc,
um,
which is our kind of virtual way to connect.
And a,
the room isn't that much bigger than this one here,
but we knew that thousands of Googlers would be listening and it was our way to
kind of test out,
uh,
Googlers willingness to get close to the issue.
And I remember on the backend calling our community partners and letting them
know,
uh,
many of them who were now supporting through our grants that this work was going
to be talked about during our company meeting.
And I actually didn't share how big that meeting was.
So they might think it was just a couple of folks who are interested in hearing
more about their work.
Um,
but the response from Googlers that day and to this day,
um,
Google shore challenging themselves to learn more about this issue and in
supporting the folks that have boots on the ground,
um,
it really inspires us on our team to keep moving the company forward.
And challenging ourselves to,
um,
discuss this conversation and push where we haven't pushed before.
So our employees have hosted movie screenings on mass incarceration both on
campus and in the community policy convenings like today on criminal justice
brought some of the nation's most prominent speakers and voices in the movement,
folks like Brian Stevenson and Gina Clayton,
um,
to our campus and our volunteering and the communities and in prisons.
And we think that's very important.
We're very excited now to be a testing out,
uh,
Googlers actually getting in the,
on the ground in the office and working alongside one of our community partners,
center for policing equity to engineer systems,
um,
and help build a national database that can help,
uh,
reduce bias and policing.
And so I just wanted to share with the room that we're pushing ourselves to get
smarter and do more.
Um,
and I want to encourage everyone who's listening,
uh,
from the company side on the GBC today to really just continue your volunteering
you're giving and learn more about this issue.
Um,
and as we are challenged today,
make an intentional effort to support,
um,
and share our platform with women and girls who are directly impacted.
You can go to go slash get proximate if you're listening in to get involved with
our volunteering efforts@google.org uh,
in criminal justice.
And then for the folks who are in the room,
uh,
let's please find ways to collaborate.
If you have a creative idea on how we can share our platforms,
please find me after this event or you can reach out to me my email dresses m a
B
map@googledotorgandyoucanlearnmoreaboutourcriminaljusticegrantmakingeffortsatwww.google.work.
So thank you all for sharing,
uh,
this room with us today and for sharing your voices and your stories are really
appreciate it.
Yeah.
Um,
I want to thank everybody for being with us today and I want to give special
thanks and honor to the women and girls who not only share their narratives,
but also their expertise of how we dismantle these pipelines into incarceration
for women and girls.
I also want to say to those in the room and those who are listening in that one
powerful way of being part of this movement to make sure that our women and
girls are not left behind is to know what the National Council for formerly
incarcerated and incarcerated women and girls is up to.
If you go to their website,
you can find out how to donate to them as well as be part of the campaigns that
they are advancing.
I also want to plead to make sure that we as a company continue to be proximate,
continue to recognize that this issue is at the center of all of our work and
communities and lives that need is not marginal.
That it is part of how we can use our goodness and use our wisdom and use our
platforms to make sure that we live in a society where everyone is valued,
where every life,
where every mother child bond is honored and has the chance to be.
And finally I want to close this out on two notes of gratitude,
a gratitude to Topeka,
Sam for helping us bring the right
women.
Take.
Keep thinking about ways to use tech to scale the prison walls and we tried to
do that today and thank you to Pika for helping us to do that.
To bring the voices of Miss Alice and Ms Sandra into our space and I also want
to give special thanks to Greer Stockman who allowed this all to come together.
Thank you for all of the courage that was shown today and we are going to close
out with Kristen,
the n allowing us to just breathe in this moment and think how we are going to
move forward in the work before us.
Thank you.
Hi everyone.
Um,
there's two songs I want to play for you today that I think are very fitting.
and before I do,
while I set up and tune my instrument over here,
if anyone that's the way in the distance feels far away and wants to come over
to this side,
we'll have a second for you to do that.
The first song I want to play is called the escape and it's from an album that's
coming out later this year.
And this song,
the single actually is going to drop on Thursdays.
So you guys are hearing it before everyone else and it's called the escape
because,
uh,
my new album is about a character who escapes a prison.
And I wrote this,
I wrote this song not just about escaping a physical prison,
but the kind that we impose on ourselves in terms of the kind of self love we
give ourselves or how we allow other people to dictate who we are and what we
can be.
So,
um,
I hope you enjoy it.
And then I'll explain the second song here.
So thank you very much.
Mm.
Mm,
mm,
mm
[inaudible]
thank you.
Thank you so much for everyone's sharing stories today.
It was just an incredible day.
And um,
leads me to why I want to play this next song that I wrote called unconditional,
and I call it unconditional because I wanted to write a song that captured the
essence of unconditional love.
Not just any kind of love but unconditional.
It's the kind that loves you not only in your best moments,
but your worst moments.
You know,
I kind of love that accepts you for who you are,
including the highest version of yourself.
And then that monster that comes out sometimes that we're ashamed of,
but is a part of us.
You know,
the,
the stories of our lives that we can't be without,
because as hard as they are,
they made us,
they are us.
So I wanted to see if I could read a song,
even if without lyrics,
that could capture that feeling of what it means to be unconditionally loved.
For those of us who know that feeling.
Because even though everyone deserves unconditional love,
not everyone has it.
So I thought if I could capture it in a song,
we could all share it.
Thank you.
[inaudible]
no.
[inaudible].